centralized control speaker so thank you
very much to the organizers for having
me
they try and quickly recover from that
last video so I changed the title of the
talk a little bit so I kind of had to
look at what other people were talking
about in the meeting and I had a bit of
a think about you know what you know
societal networks probably isn't quite a
thing yet so I had to think about
different projects that I've been
involved with that have some notion of
societal networks associated with them
so it's a bit of a kind of smorgasbord
of different projects and topics some of
which is very old and unpublished some
of which is kind of ongoing projects the
list of collaborators here so Lachlan
Andrew high view and tong li are all in
Monash in Melbourne in Australia and
they were involved with some projects to
do with simulating traffic lights
Peter Appleby Thomas house and Jack
Mackenzie were all involved in the
project with a company called auto trade
where Peters the data scientist some
work on queueing with Maurey Bramson
bernardo Doria and some work on auctions
with peter key and Frank and then
finally but not least this my sort of
northmost co-organizers Richard Connors
Ian Watling and Mike Smith and we kind
of organized this kind of north of
England
workshop on transport modeling and
mathematics with transport modeling and
we have sort of two meetings a year one
which is an academic meeting and one
meeting that's like a transport
consultants meeting where we invite
various people when they talk about what
sort of simulation models they're using
and things like this okay so so so like
I say this talk is an overview of
various projects and they all involve
cars in some way shape or form either
cars virtually cars online or cars
exchanging positions physically in the
road okay
and for each of these is going to be
notions of social network analysis
auctions and online marketplaces and
also control
and I figured you know given the theme
of the workshop and the other talk so
these are kind of three themes within
the kind of societal networks theme okay
right so the first part I'll talk about
which is it's like very very very old
work from when so I did a a internship
at Microsoft Research with Peter key and
we're meant to be looking at various
auction data from Bing and then the data
took a long time to arrive for I started
this initial project looking at the
exchange of cars on a Microsoft Xbox
platform okay so that's the Microsoft
Xbox 360 and for that they had this
computer game called ports a motorsport
number two okay and then on this you can
essentially base cars and then you race
the cars and get money and you also get
cars which you can then personalize and
then sell okay so for example here we're
close to Easter so here's a cream egg
car if you've no crab I'm sure if you
get Cadbury's cream eggs in America but
okay anyway so you can personalize this
it can be very personalized and then you
go online and you sell them on auction
house which is an online platform where
the you know the several hundred
thousand users who then go online and
trade and sell their cars for gain money
okay all right so this is just a bunch
of descriptive statistics about this
auction place to start with just kind of
set a way of thinking about these things
okay so here's a picture over time of
the number of auctions that take place
per day is renormalized on the y-axis
for kind of because not allowed to give
all the data away but you can see here
clearly the Japanese release date
followed by the US release date and then
the European release date and you can
also notice that there are kind of peaks
on the weekends because people gain more
on the weekends and they do during the
week so that all makes sense okay and
one of the most interesting things I
found about this this data set was the
way the kind of auction structure and
the way things changed over time so it
was an eBay style auction so you have a
reserve price and you also have a buyout
price so you can also
decide if you want to set a price that
you can guarantee to buy that item for
okay and what you see here is the
average reserve price at the bottom the
average buyout price which is sort of
the thick line that ends up in the
middle and the average sale price okay
and the one of the things I found most
interesting about this is it sort of
seems to be sort of three phases to this
auction as it gets released so there's a
kind of initial phase where all the cars
are sold at the reserve price then as
almost like a kind of like a phase
transition almost where people suddenly
discover they've got enough money and
when they go into the marketplace they
just buy the cars at the buyout price
okay so things kind of go from everyone
just pays the minimum amount they can
it's kind of a thin auction okay with
only kind of one buyer for a car then it
goes to a situation where it becomes
kind of rich people get wealthy this
competition and then people just go well
I just find the first car I can buy the
buyout price and then it goes beyond
that where people start to specialize
and personalize their cars and then we
get this kind of very heavy oscillatory
behavior in the average reserve price I
mean the average price of the cars which
is this kind of Wiggly behavior over
here okay so the auctions start that
move to be close to the buyout and then
go to this kind of crazy phase where
there's a big fluctuation in the buyout
price and actually what we find from the
data is actually a relatively small
number of people entering the auctions
causing these big oscillations okay
which then indicate something that's
really going on in this system okay so
so why is this happening well if you
look at the kind of the graph of the
trades which are going on in this you
can notice that it's got kind of like a
social network type formation so if you
look at the number of the degree of each
user in terms of the number of bids that
they're making and take logs on both
axes for this distribution then you see
that there's a kind of a power law
degree distribution going on in this
graph okay
so that's something very typical of kind
of what it's a complex networks okay
though in this auction system there's no
notion of a social network associated
with it so people don't
No who else are buying and selling so
there's another source of this power law
effect so when people talk about the
rich get rich or effect
yeah actually is a people getting richer
and gain money and then guess causing
themselves to get richer and you can
then plot for example the I think this
is the sales distribution complementary
cumulative distribution of a number of
sales and it's approximately kind of a
log normal type of distribution for the
Wealth's that people are doing in terms
of their expenditures okay so it's kind
of interesting and then then you can
also look at the connectivity graph and
do various kind of graph analysis of the
kind of distances and clustering
coefficients and things like this so we
do some of that so this is June the 11th
we just looked at all the people go
inactive on June 11th about 21,000
people ok the majority of which are
connected to the giant component of this
graph ok and it's quite a sparse graph
as well ok so even just within a single
day you see a kind of complex network
type structure arriving if people are
entering buying and selling within this
auction ok
then at this point all the data arrived
on from Bing search and I kind of spent
time looking at that and you know these
kind of analysis kind of changed my view
about the way to look at auctions so a
lot of the kind of auction theory that
I'd kind of read about you know you have
this idea of kind of a fixed static
auction with a fixed set of buyers ok
and then you can do mechanism design on
this but actually the reality of these
kind of online systems is more very
complicated there's large pools of
people that come together and then kind
of go away and then don't see each other
for a long time and then come back
together and don't see each other for a
long time and so that is something that
you know we felt needed to be taken
account for in the way the auctions are
designed and the kind of mechanism
design questions and so we you know in
there in the kind of so after these kind
of which is just really exploratory data
analysis after this we kind of began to
look into kind of auction mechanisms ok
so uh we wrote a paper about this Peter
key Frank Kelly myself on efficient
advert assignments so given that the
interactions on online of auctions form
a complex network mechanism design
should take account for that so really
when people go online to an online
platform might be more Google or
something like this they should just see
they'll probably just get like an
average click-through rate or number of
clicks on their different adverts which
they buy via auction okay the sets of
people that they compete with over those
auctions is constantly changing in this
random okay and in fact the sets of
types of auctions is so massive that you
shouldn't really be assuming that you're
working with a single auction type okay
so he basically looked into kind of a
way of thinking about these and looking
at each organ as an individual component
of a large distributed optimization okay
so we wrote a paper on this and kind of
a massively distributed VCG mechanism
where for like let's say every tau of a
sample space of some probability
distribution
you'd an individual VCG auction and does
that give you an efficient outcome eat a
latarian socially optimal outcome
overall and you can get that to work out
okay so so that was one kind of line of
work which has faced an issue on some
exploratory data analysis and then lead
to kind of sandpapers theoretically what
we were doing in terms of this work to
get the mechanism design parts to work
out is following this line of work of
which Bruce is in the audience and
remeasure Hari was here yesterday they
had this idea of kind of scalar
parameterised GCG mechanisms we kind of
do that for a kind of larger
distribution and also you know VCG is
something which is a type of auction
mechanism it's something that's you know
taken quite seriously since the paper by
Harris and Hal Varian who's the chief
economist at Google where they look into
how they go about implementing these
types of ECG mechanisms it's certainly
something that's in their mind so I went
a few years back when I came to
California went down to Google and met
some of the folks who implement this
stuff and had a bit of a chat about you
know VCG there
all right so so if if kind of the
analysis of that fort sir motorsport was
kind of like you know bitcoins if you
know what I mean now it's like let's
think about like real cars okay so when
I arrived in in Manchester Manchester
University have been there for about two
years now I realize there's some
projects going on we've just been
approached by a company called Auto
Trader okay
and I don't think auto trader has a very
big profile in America but it has quite
a big footprint in the UK and it's
something that initially started out as
kind of like a paper magazine in the 70s
80s okay if you wanted to get a new
second-hand car they'd publish this
magazine every month okay and put all
their second-hand cars on it and then
people go in this way
okay so if you ask anyone say above the
age of 40 they just think of it as a
paper magazine okay
though what's happened is it's it sort
of grew its online business in the early
2000s okay and then slowly moved into
actually they don't have a paper
magazine anymore and it's just an online
marketplace for second-hand cars okay so
that's what auto trade looks like today
okay so it's a it's a firstly 250
company it's got about what about three
billion to three billion and basically
the about 85% of second-hand cars in the
UK go on to this website okay alright so
I think in recent times about two three
years have kind of realized that really
the value of their company is one the
amount of coverage they have over the UK
car market particularly secondhand car
market which is a reasonably big lot of
people buy second-hand cars in the UK is
that their data is really quite
important to them and they've sort of
grown us a smallish data science team
which are now kind of engaging with the
University of Manchester because they're
based in Manchester okay
so this is what happens when you search
for a different type of car you get a
list of cars it's all very you know like
you're used to these kinds of online
businesses okay so it's just going to
explain some of the projects we've been
doing with
and some of the practicalities around
that again it's a little bit descriptive
statistics and is a bit of this kind of
Thompson sampling stuff that we heard
about yesterday okay so quite applied
again okay so this is a work of editor
who was a MSC student with us in
Manchester and she worked on various
issues around clustering analysis of
their data in terms of the different
types of cars
okay she's now a marketing analyst at
Nestle okay so we basically just looked
at how to cluster the different types of
cars together so here's one with a
method called affinity propagation okay
and then a second clustering analysis
with something called k-means plus k
plus plus means okay so sort of k-means
but with the kind of warm start okay so
get a slightly better initial
configuration and you can see here here
it does quite a good job for example we
notice that the red cluster contains
Audis BMWs and Mercedes Benz and so it's
able to kind of just by looking at the
characteristics of the cars come up with
classifications of the kind of car
groupings and that's something that
they're kind of quite interested in
because previously they've done things
through sort of psychologist surveys
where they kind of asked a bunch of
people you know what kind of person you
you were kind of adventurous by or you
kind of you know someone who needs a
people carrier and things like this and
we kind of want to move away from that
to something where they're actually
looking at the data and the way people
access the website in order to kind of
characterize the different kinds of
users so so Shrikant talk for example on
topic modeling has been very relevant to
some of the things that we're starting
to look into as well so so kind of e/m
algorithms to kind of decide what
interest people have
okay so one of the interesting things
about looking at their cars also is
looking temporarily over time the
changes in the number of cars that are
discontinued and looking at that through
the data and you can see that actually
the EE regulations on cars have a big
impact on the types of cars that are
being released okay so you see big Peaks
where a new piece of e eu Admissions
regulation is brought in okay
so I can imagine you know as things we
call more electric and renewable you can
see these sorts of impacts coming
through so you might not initially
anticipate that obviously they are
designing these regulations to change
the size of cars to be maybe they are
having quite a big impact okay so that's
that was what editor looked into in her
thesis summer okay we also before that
we had another MSC student Jake McKenzie
who's now doing a PhD with us funded by
Autotrader so so Jack kind of turned up
we had the idea of doing some stuff on
recommendation systems I knew about some
of the stuff like trueskill which was
kind of Microsoft's click-through
prediction ranking mechanism which is
all published work so we looked into
that and then we kind of continued and
so now we're kind of looking into
implementing different forms of multi on
Bandits on auto traders website so aside
from some work on kind of queueing
systems and multi on Bandits and regret
for queueing systems I haven't really
worked systematically on multi on
Bandits as a research topic so I kind of
been reading a bit of the literature not
trying to prove regret bouncer just
trying to come up with an algorithm
that's going to work on this this
website okay so so what happened so I
just explained the story so far with
that it's not finished yet so it's kind
of in progress with with Jack's PhD but
essentially we see a ranking of cars and
the top-ranked car there is a featured
listing so these are cut these are
garages are paying a premium to have
their car ranked higher okay
and Autotrader would outsource this to a
company called hook logic okay and then
about just as Jack was sort of finishing
his MSC hook logic got bought out and
then auto trade were like ah what we
going to do you know and so we were kind
of working on this kind of stuff and
they thought well we'll just keep this
project going and then we're kind of
essentially looking to replace what well
hook logic have now gone and we're now
replacing their way of listing this top
advert with a kind of multi-armed bandit
approach okay so it's just to explain a
little bit of the story so far with that
so current consultancy is bought out so
then we have to deal with like some of
the practicalities that some of these
websites you know they've only recently
started to hire data scientists and a
lot of the people are kind of like
people from like done Humby so people
like you do market analysis for Tesco
and things like this on products and
things like this rather than this kind
of staff so they haven't been recording
that people don't click on adverts they
just call them record the number of
clicks so there's something that's quite
common across different online
businesses maybe not in California but
in the UK that's that's an issue okay so
we have to get them to work to record
their non clicks and then we're just
going to implement vanilla Thompson
sampling is so that's that's coming in
in a few weeks now probably a couple of
weeks they're going to implement
Thompson sampling and and and and like
was mentioned yesterday in the talk it's
if you've got someone who's like been
working for like a marketing consultant
as a data scientist they know logistic
regression and it's and they also know
Bayesian logistic regression okay so you
can explain that to them they say well
you just do the section Monte Carlo step
on it and then you implement it so it's
a very so rather next you know rather
than getting Silas theorem and trying to
explain k lu k lu c b and this kind of
stuff
although the bounds are better in terms
of the practical implementation
explaining it to people is just
massively easier okay
so we'll be implementing the kind of
normal thompson sampling and then
looking into the practicalities to do in
the next step so one things mentioned
was this yahoo paper which first looked
into thompson sampling and and one of
the issues you have there is that
although normal thompson sampling
has a conjugate prior okay so meaning
that you've got a closed form expression
for the normalizing constant if you're
trying to do something that's going to
have various covariance associated with
it that's no longer the case
and so we've got to look into the
practicalities of the kind of
normalizing constants that we're going
to use so their various approximation
mech methods I mean you can do straight
Montecarlo but that's going to be slow
so we've looked into kind of a class
approximation variational Bayes which
looks into kind of a product form
structure with with the normalizing
constant and expectation propagation
okay and then as we're wanting to kind
of introduce more features of the users
that are coming in that's what we're
going to start using hopefully start to
use more topic modeling and things like
this to try and extrapolate from the
searches that people are making what
they're actually interested in what
categories of cars okay there's lots of
things to do there it's been quite fun
so far obviously this is something
that's just going to get implemented for
that top slot we want to kind of broaden
it out to the rest of the adverts they
currently have a system where they
essentially just call up different
garages and just say hey you know what
you want this week this kind of thing
and I kind of think they should change
the mechanism that they use for selling
these adverts whether we can convince
them is a different matter I mean
they're used to their you know they've
got a system that works for them said I
want to change too much and the other
aspect is revenue management I mean
they've got very unique data on the
prices and how to change those of
different cars as well so for some of
the bigger car companies if something's
on the forecourt for over say six weeks
I'll put it out to auction and there's a
clear revenue maximization problem that
they have there in terms of how they
drop the prices up until it comes into
auction something I really want to work
with them on that we've got to kind of
do this problem first and then you know
build up trust and then go from there
okay so that's where that project lie so
so cars virtual cars cars online and
then now want to kind of talk a little
bit about cars on the road and
scheduling those okay so again
stochastic environment resource
scheduling
okay so when I was in Amsterdam we had a
PhD student Peter Kovaks and his topic
was essentially traffic scheduling and
the thought at the time was like well
there's all this stuff in communications
literature surely that should transfer
over quite seamlessly to scheduling of
junctions in traffic systems okay and
kind of as this project went on further
and we did cat-eyed was kind of doing
additional research on the side kind of
came up with a different view of things
but you know not so so here's the kind
of thing would be used to in the
communications literature that's an
input cued switch okay which would be a
kind of core internet Rueter and there's
matching constraints bipartite matching
constraints on this system in a very
similar way to the way you'd have a
junction where there's constraints on
the system due to conflicting traffic
was talking about earlier okay okay
and then you connect these things
together to make networks and those
notions of things like I sit TCP
fairness max weight back pressure
proportional fairness they're all kind
of things that used to in that
literature okay whereas in the traffic
kind of domain there's obviously a
different nomenclature this is a
simulation software which we worked with
sumo but there's a lot of different
types of simulation software's this is
one that's free publicly available but
also used by traffic engineers these are
the kind of systems we're looking at so
these are my collaborators in Melbourne
that's the Melbourne CB is downtown
Melbourne in this in the center of the
city there okay and the kinds of things
they look at I like web tags which can a
UK government legislation around
Transport Systems Saturn which is like a
long term planning software made by the
I TS and lead so as the the guys in
Leeds in the northmost group and then
you have different vehicle actuated
control mechanisms so scoot and mover
there are made by the transport Research
Laboratory in the UK which is probably
the main leading vehicle actuators
software at the moment and I kind of
went down to visit them to kind of chat
about what they were doing but I think
there's
a lot of room for improvement on what
they currently do and then scats is a
Australian version from Sydney and then
you've got utopia which is probably the
next closest rival to this scoot traffic
assignment software and then roads is a
further system okay so I kind of wanted
to put the word real-time in in the
title because then it fits within the
topic and the talk okay so why do
real-time and I want to do some very
basic queueing Theory my main background
is not statistics or machine learning
but queuing okay so we have a single
server that can serve one of two queues
which has an arrival rate okay you can
do any schedule on that red line there
so from serving all the top would be
serving everything in Junction 2 and the
bottom will be serving everything the
first queue okay so if you have I think
prepping when you talk at the planning
meeting for this said that like
something like 97% of us junctions are
fixed cycle so why is fixed cycle a bad
thing well the stability region of this
is a subset of what you can actually
achieve let's say you do 50/50 you
divide your servers 50/50 between those
two junctions and that's the set of
rates that you can stabilize okay
whereas if you did something like
longest queue um it's generalization max
weight then you get the whole region one
reason why using things that are vehicle
actuated or real-time based on the
current state of the system is a good
thing to do so adaptive adaptive is
better for maximizing throughput okay
here's another reason okay let's suppose
I continue with that longest queue
analog and I did some calculations
assuming everything's Markovian I can
calculate the stationery expect to queue
size of that okay so as a row divided by
1 minus Rho okay and I can also do it if
I did the fixed cycle length okay and
what you can realize is that you get
half the queue size by being adaptive
compared to what you get if you are not
adaptive okay so in the kind of
stochastic networks rich - you'd call
that resource pooling okay so even if
both stabilize the system longest cubed
resources together and makes factor of
two improvement in this system okay and
the same is true for those images if we
did max weights Shrikant has to you know
these results where you say that rod
that fixed scheduling of an input q
switch would have like an N squared
complexity where n is the number of
ports whereas something like max I would
have an N and I also did some some work
on that okay so it seems like we should
do something like longest queue or max
wait and this is kind of where like
halfway through doing this project yeah
one minute okay we realize that actually
you can prove that longest queue service
isn't maximally stable okay so actually
if you serve the longest queue if you
connect these things together to make
junctions then you're not going to have
maximum stability okay so you can
simulate this kind of junction you end
up with this kind of oscillatory
behavior so networks of Cusick connected
together or imp accuse witches to do
longest queue aren't going to be the
best necessarily okay I think I got one
minute the main point that I want to
make is you should do something that's
more kind of fair to each Junction so
you should do something proportional to
the queue length so if you want to do it
on a setting like this which would be
unstable under longest queue you want to
do something is proportional to the
lengths of the numbers of jobs of
different queues okay
[Applause]
not yet I mean okay so mostly here we
consider everything kind of without any
specific priority a separate project
with a PhD student might were looking at
how you can maintain maximum throughput
whilst having priorities between
different drum machines Shrikant has a
nice paper that does this does maximum
stability he didn't have priorities in
that paper but I think you can adapt his
proof to do that well you can adapt his
proof to do that so there is ways of
getting priorities which is important
for pedestrians and things like this is
thanks to having me